all right good morning everyone I'm
Joshua a I work in the Stanford
intelligence systems lab and my research
is largely focused on autonomous
exploration so as you can imagine a
large part of that involves decision-
making under uncertainty specifically
reasoning about how we plan out a series
of actions into the future and
quantifying and sort of thinking about
how the uncertainty will propagate
through those actions and so very
closely related to that is what we're
going to be talking about today which is
policy optimization so with policy
optimization where we're sort of going
to start is looking at this
parameterized policy that we set up and
then looking at just sort of local
changes that we can make to it so that's
sort of the policy search section then
we're going to transition to talking
about how can we estimate the gradient
with respect to that policy and we're
going to use that gradient estimate to
then help us optimize our policy okay so
that's sort of the the layout the scope
for policy optimization but I think
before diving into any of that it's
helpful to sort of Zoom all the way out
look at the big picture Orient ourselves
of where we are what we're doing and why
we're doing it okay so we have this sort
of model that we're working with here
where we have an agent acting in some
environment and the agent can take an
action and receive some observation okay
so this is very general right the agent
could be a ro on the surface of another
planet or it could be a financial
trading agent that's making buy and sell
decisions right it's very very general
so maybe if we go one to two levels down
now we have this idea of the the marov
decision process right which is saying
essentially the same thing as the
picture on the left just with a little
more structure so we have some agent in
a state that agent can take actions and
based on the action that it takes in
that state it receives some reward and
then transitions to a new state
okay so this idea of receiving rewards
in a particular State sort of brings out
the idea of the utility function which
is telling us what's the utility or
value for being in a particular State
okay and then linked to that we have
this idea of the policy and that's what
we're talking about today so the policy
is like our our strategy right it's how
we how we take actions it's telling us
how we what action we should take in a
particular State okay so that's the sort
of big picture we should keep in mind as
we're going through this right that's
all of these pieces fit together and now
we're going to dive into the details of
it okay so we're starting with policy
search and policy search is really
focused on just searching the space of
policies okay so it's exactly what's in
the title right so how we're going to
start here is by parameterizing our
policy okay so we're going to represent
our
policy with some some Vector of
parameters here that we're going to call
our thetas okay so we have n different
parameters that we're calling Theta 1 to
Theta n okay so these parameters right
now could be anything really they're
whatever we want we're not saying how
we're parameterizing our policy we're
just saying that we have these
parameters okay so our policy could be
parameterized by some neural network
right and these would be the weights and
biases of our neural network but it
doesn't have to be it can be some other
General function question when you say
poliy sear how does it differ or how
does it fit into the world of like what
we learned about like lectures ago with
like policy like
policy that's a great question that's
exactly where we're going to next so
we're going to yeah we'll we'll dive
into that you want to repeat question oh
the question was how does policy search
relate to what we've seen in the past
with like value iteration or policy
iteration so we'll see that right now so
we have these the set of parameters here
and we can say our policy now is just
this Pi Theta so our policy just
parameterized by these this set of
parameters okay so now going to your
question what we've seen in the past is
that we can we know we can say what the
utility when following a particular
policy is right so we've seen that we
can say the utility when following a
policy from some State s is equal to the
immediate reward that we receive right
plus the action for for the action that
our policy tells us to take in that
state and then we have the discounted
future reward here so some over all next
states that we could then transition
to when following that
policy okay and then we also have the U
of S Prime that's cut off here so that's
in there okay so that's that's telling
us the utility when following a
particular policy okay but that's only
from a certain state so what we want to
sort of get an idea of now is the
utility of our policy in general right
not just from one state but from every
possible state that we could be in okay
so what that looks like is when we say
the utility of a
policy we're talking about so this is
utility of a policy parameterized by
Theta what we'll do is we're going to
equivalently just write this as U of
theta okay so this is just sort of
shorthand notation here to sort of drop
the the pi Theta because really what
controls our policy is these parameters
okay so these mean the same thing here
it's just sort of convention all right
so what we're saying now is we want the
utility of our policy in general right
so what we're going to do is we're going
to look at over every possible state
that we could be in the probability that
we're in that state then times the
utility when following our policy from
that state okay so that's what we mean
when we're talking about this general
idea of the utility of a a particular
policy okay so using the same concept
that we've seen in the past and now
applying it to looking at every possible
state that we could be in this is the
probability that we're in that state
okay so in practice though this is
pretty hard to compute right if if we
have a very large State space or our
state space is continuous it's almost
impossible right to get this actual
quantitative value okay so that's that's
what we want to talk about now is how
can we actually approximate this utility
of a policy right because in practice
when we're working with large scale
problems it's not not feasible to
directly compute this question
um when you say BFS the previous one
like T the transition probabilities make
sense but how do you calculate a general
probability for what the probability
yeah good question so this would be
either you have some some prior
knowledge of what the uh what the uh
probability would be of starting in that
particular State you may you might have
some data set in which case you could
sort of back out a probability from that
data but some some domain knowledge that
you have here would sort of give you
this this prior knowledge of what the
probability of being in that state
is and sorry the question was uh how do
we know this this B of s here okay so we
want to come up with a way that we can
get some approximation for this utility
okay and that's what we're going to talk
about now and I think it helps to sort
of start with this visual example
here so for this example consider that
you're a Rover on the surface of Mars
okay and let's say that we're pretty
sure our Rover is starting somewhere in
this ellipse region we're not exactly
sure where but we have some initial
belief about where we think the Rover is
here so what we're going to do to
estimate this utility here is we're
going to simulate policy rollouts okay
and that's what we're going to visualize
here so to simulate a policy roll out
what we do we have this initial belief
distribution we're going to sample an
initial state from that so this
distribution could be a gaussian
distribution could be a uniform
distribution doesn't matter right now
we're just saying we have some
distribution that we're starting with we
sample an initial state from that
distribution and then we're going to
give that state to our policy so we say
hey policy I'm in this state right now
what should I do the policy says you
should go one meter forward so you go
one meter forward and then now you ask
your policy again what should I do now
turn one meter to the right so you turn
one meter to the right and then you ask
your policy again now it says go one
meter forward and you just continue to
do that and you roll out your policy
into the Future Okay so that's a policy
roll out so we do that we roll out our
policy to some depth that we specified
and we get a trajectory now so that's
one policy roll out that we've done we
can repeat this process right we can
repeat it as many times as we want so we
sample a new state now and then we roll
out our policy into the Future Okay and
we can just continue repeating this in
our case we'll do this three times here
so now we have three trajectories that
we've rolled out into the
future with each of these right we have
some reward model that we can then sort
of query right for each of these
trajectories that we roll out we get
some Associated reward so this top one
probably is not so good right because it
drives us over the Rocks there that's
going to be a very bumpy ride for our
Rover so we don't like that the middle
one does a little bit better but still
gets us sort of close to the Rock so not
great and then this bottom one we'd say
okay that's that's pretty good steers us
clear there okay so we have that
approximation now that we've done just
with these by simulating these policy
roll outs into the future so now we're
going to use that to come back to how do
we estimate this utility of our
policy
okay so what we're going to do here is
we've collected these trajectory
rollouts that we've simulated okay so
now we can
say utility of our
policy is just the expected reward that
we think will receive along those
trajectories okay so this is just an
expectation over the rewards that we got
right the red yellow and green
trajectories those were the rewards that
we received so we're taking the
expectation over that so from the
definition of just expectations we can
write this out in an integral form where
we have the
probability of that trajectory occurring
when following our particular policy
okay and then just from definition of
expectation it's just time of the reward
right expectation is probability of This
this term times the term right and then
we just integrate that that's the
expectation okay so again yes
question
about like if there are some cases where
we
really yeah so the question was are
there cases where we care about how
variable the reward might be so that's
an excellent question and that's a very
big part part of policy optimization in
general is that the variance of the
rewards from your policy rollouts tends
to be quite high so dealing with that
variance is a big Challenge and that's
something we're going to get to later so
that's a great
question okay so we we have this
expectation
here and sort of similar to what we have
before right we're we're not actually
going to compute this integral maybe in
in certain cases where we have a simple
uh simple policy set up we could do this
but in the general sense we're going to
approximate this with Monte Carlo
samples okay so we we know we've already
sampled our uh our different policy
trajectories here and to approximate
this integral we're going to say that
this is approximately equal to just the
average reward that we receive along our
trajectories where this
is this is the I trajectory
so we go from IAL 1 to M okay so in in
that example that we saw we we did three
policy rollouts right so we had three
trajectories so n was three here and
then we're just averaging the reward
right so the average between red yellow
and green that would give us somewhere
in the yellow right so it's just an okay
policy it's not great yes so when you
say the reward do you mean the
instantaneous reward point or do you
mean like the whole like equation the
future out thing yeah good question this
is the discounted the total discounted
reward we receive along that trajectory
yep the question was when we when we say
reward here are we talking about the
immediate reward or the uh the
discounted reward into the future so
this is the discounted reward that we
receive along the whole
trajectory okay so that's how we use
this idea of policy rollouts why why are
we doing this right what what's the
point of the policy roll outs we wanted
to get this this concept of the utility
of of a particular policy this allows us
to say is a policy good or not right
it's sort of giving us some quantitative
way to say is our policy doing well okay
we saw that we would have to look at
every every possible state right so
instead of doing that we're just saying
from our current state let's simulate
trajectories out into the future and
then look at the average reward that
we're getting and that gives us this
estimate for how good is our policy
right now okay so that's that's the
whole picture of what we've looked at so
far
now we're going to use this idea for
policy search Okay so this was just sort
of the setup of how we sort of quantify
is a policy good or
not so what we're going to start with is
local search okay so what we're showing
here in this picture you have Theta 2 on
the Y AIS Theta 1 is on the x axis so
this is just a very simple policy okay
it's just a two we have two parameters
in this policy Theta 1 and Theta 2 very
simple okay and what we're showing in
the color scheme there is the utility of
of those parameters which we don't we
don't know that to start with right so
we we don't know any of that that's sort
of hidden to us but for the
visualization we're seeing it in the
background okay so what we do is we
start with our current parameters so our
current set of theta 1 and Theta 2 puts
us right here okay then what we do in
local search is we just simply take a
sort of plus step and a minus step along
each parameter Direction okay so because
we have two parameters here that would
lead us to taking 2 N so 2 * n where n
is the number of parameters that's the
number of candidate points we're going
to evaluate okay so here we have two
parameters 2 * 2 is four so we're
looking at four candidate parameters and
that's what you're you're seeing here so
this was a plus step in the Theta 2
Direction minus step in the Theta 2
Direction skipping ahead there uh this
is a plus step in the Theta 1 minus step
in the Theta 1 okay so we're looking at
those four uh candidate points now at
each of these candidate points we have a
new set of parameters here right so with
this new set we then
do some M set of policy rollouts into
the future okay and that gives us an
estimate for our utility at each of
those uh parameter sets Okay so when we
do that we see well which one is the
best performer okay it will be this
point assuming we do a large number of
roll outs to get a reasonable estimate
so what we then do is we move our
parameters to that that candidate point
so we move over there because we said
that's the best performer and now we
just repeat this process so we again do
our 2 N we evaluate our two n candidate
points we do M sets of trajectory roll
outs for each of those candidate points
we're looking at we get some estimate of
the utility for that particular policy
and then we step to the direction of the
best one so here the best one will be
this one and I should mention the the
dark blue color here that's the the
higher utility the green and yellow is
the lower utility okay so we step to
that bottom point now and then we just
repeat again so we look which one of
these four candidate points has the
highest utility well it's the lowest one
so we're going to step to the lowest one
again we we repeat this process again
it's that lowest point there so we move
down there but now notice when we're
here the best performing point is this
one okay and it might be hard to see
that color gradient but it is this point
here so none of the candidate points
we're evaluating are better than the the
point that we're currently at so what do
we do now well we're going to shrink now
we shrink our step size so we bring our
step size in and now we're not stepping
as far in each candidate Direction okay
so now we evaluate does anyone improve
no so we're going to shrink again and we
just continue shrinking down until we
get a better candidate point so in this
case we've shrunk down and now actually
the one on the right is the better
performer and so we step there and you
just repeat this process over and over
until you reach some threshold where
your step size has dropped between and
we call that our convergence Point okay
so that's that's our local search
method parameter being updated or are
there cases where multiple updated at
the
I guess
it's right yes good question so yeah you
you because we're stepping in sort of
that plus or minus for each of our
candidate parameters right we'll end up
taking just the the one candidate point
that was the best performer so it was
only going to be that changing one of
those
parameters yep are you showing the
utility or
the and the diagram we showing the
utility so the blue is the is the higher
uh
yeah the better
value okay so some of the issues with
this right this kind of seems like it's
reasonable right but this was a case
where we only had two parameters so if
we have you know billions of parameters
this is going to be not very feasible
right because for each of these
candidate points we have to do a set a
new set of M rollouts so that's just
going to take forever if our parameter
set is very large okay and then the
other sort of factor here is that we
have to we have to set the step size
right to begin with we have to choose
that initial step size so that could be
a tuning parameter due to you know
whatever you think your utility space
looks like so those are sort of some of
the drawbacks of this local search
method so the next method that we're
going to talk about is the cross entropy
method and this is very similar idea to
local search but goes about it in
slightly different way okay so what
we're working with here now
with the cross entropy
method is a search distribution okay so
before we were just taking those fixed
step size now we're introducing this
idea of a search distribution and our
search distribution we write as P Theta
of s okay so s here is our search
distribution parameters so don't get
confused here because Theta is our our
policy parameters and S our search
distribution parameters okay so what do
we mean by that a common choice for our
search distribution would just be a
gaussian distribution okay so if we're
using a gaussian distribution all s is
is just the mean and covariance of our
gaussian distribution okay so that's
what SII is we still what we really care
about right is our our Theta parameters
that's what we're trying to change here
our search distribution is just now sort
of how we're going to be moving around
the policy space okay so we have this
search distribution we have our search
distribution parameters for now let's
say we're working with a gaussian
distribution
okay so I think it it helps to see this
visually to sort of understand what's
going
on so with our our search distribution
here what we're showing the these white
contour lines that's our search
distribution okay so that's our gaussian
distribution that we're showing with the
contour lines
there what we're going to do now is so
for now ignore these uh the red points
just treat them as if they were all
white points okay so what we do how how
the cross entropy method works is we
start by taking M samples of theta from
this search distribution okay so from
this initial distribution that we have
shown by these contour lines we take M
samples so those are all these white and
red points treat them as if they were
all white right now okay so we take
those M samples those give us our
candidate points so those are our
starting candidate points that we want
to
evaluate
very similar to local search right we
now for each of those candidate points
we do our M set of policy rollouts to
get some estimate of the utility for
each of those
points and then what we're going to do
we're going to look at okay which of
those candidate points are our best
performers we call these our Elite
Samples so we specify some some number
of Elite Samples we can say let's take
the top five performing uh samples from
our from our candidates here okay and
those become those are these red points
here that you're seeing those are our
Elite Samples so we take our Elite
Samples and now we just refit our search
distribution so we refit our search
distribution to these Elite
performers and then we just repeat this
process okay so what does that look like
if we go through
it well we have we have those Elite
Samples there so now we're just going to
refit our distribution to it so we get
that new distribution shown there and
then we just repeat this process okay so
from our new distribution that we're
showing here we sample a new set of M
Points that's what we're showing and
then we evaluate which ones are the
Elite Samples so what are our best
performing points those are the red
points and then we refit to those red
points then we repeat this process again
where's our best performing points well
they're sort of down at the bottom so
then we refit to those and we just
continue doing this until you know our
our distribution sort of converges and
we're not really making that many
changes
anymore okay so how does this improve
upon local search well we saw that with
local search we're we're doing this 2 *
n number of candidate points every
single time right and we're only
changing each one of those one
parameters for each of those points so
the cross entropy method is a little
more efficient with how it goes about uh
sort of Distributing the samples that
we're looking at okay in addition
addition to that we specify the number
of samples so we could still have you
know billions of parameters but we're
only going to be looking at M candidate
points that we sample from that search
distribution okay so it sort of helps us
scale the problem a little bit better
you still have to do a new set of
rollouts for each of these points that
you're evaluating but we've sort of
fixed the the one of the problems with
local
search question do you do one roll per
point or do you do per the question was
do you do one roll out for each
candidate point or do you do M roll outs
so you do M roll outs for every single
point that you have you're doing m m
policy
rollouts yes that's a different M than
the number of points that samp yes yeah
thank you thank you for that Robert uh
yes so we do have two M's here uh the M
that I wrote up here for the policy roll
outs different from this m samples here
okay so sort of overloading the M there
different
M's yes you many points to
like yeah good question so the the
question was how do you decide how many
points to take for your uh M Elite
Samples uh that that would really just
be either your domain knowledge or sort
of trial and error um sort of if you
have a lot of parameters right you
should probably take more Elite Samples
to sort of get a better sense there and
also like if you're only taking one
Elite sample right that would not be so
great because you would converge very
very quickly so you sort of want to you
know it's sort of that tradeoff of
taking too many and not taking enough so
it's sort of a trial and error
there okay
great so just wrapping up sort of
summarizing what we saw with policy
search right we started with the policy
rollouts and we saw that we Ed those
policy rollouts to get us an estimate of
the utility of a particular policy
with that estimate we then use that in
local search to do this sort of fixed
step size in each parameter Direction
and then do those roll outs to evaluate
the policy in each of those directions
and then what we just saw was cross
entropy and that sort of changes on
local search where now we're using this
search distribution
instead okay so
yes like a bu of rolls a bunch of sample
points doesn't that seem very
competation expensive yes that is a
great great point so the the question
was if we have uh to do a new set of M
rollouts for each one of these sample
points isn't that very computationally
expensive and the answer is in the
general sense yes right that's pretty
inefficient to do all of those roll outs
every single time we're looking at a new
uh candidate point and so that's sort of
where we're going now is how can we
avoid having to do these new uh this new
set of rollouts every time we want to
make a change okay and so the the whole
Focus now is of how can we get more
efficient in these evaluations yes a
little bit when you say mon policy
evaluation when you sample the initial
stat use for alls do you do the whole
Monty Caro business of like oh if we saw
this a lot we don't select
it if we saw this a lot we don't last
time we mentioned that mon like with u
like for instance with Monte research
you would like keep track of how many
like start States you ended up at and
you say we don't want to go to states
that we ended up at too much yeah I see
I see what you're saying yeah so this is
different from Monte Carlo tree search
what we mean by the mon Monte Carlo
estimates here is just where we sample
from our
distribution and then we do this sort of
this is this is our Monte Carlo estimate
here where we've just we're
approximating the integral over there
this expectation we're approximating
that with the samples of the
trajectories that we've taken yeah good
question so different from monage
research yes the we're choosing a
specified yes yeah so we we set the
depth that we want to go to so we could
say we want to take you know 10 actions
so our depth would be 10 and we're going
to do that roll out for 10 different
actions oh each of those 10 states we
end up in we'll multiply by the discount
back depending on how far long
yes yep yeah so the question was for
that depth that we specify uh we're
we're looking at the discounted reward
essentially along what we receive
okay so we're going to sort of zoom out
again to the big picture right we just
looked at policy search the main idea
that we're working with right is that we
have this parameterized policy okay so
we have some set of parameters and
that's how we're sort of representing
our policy and we're looking at
estimating the utility of that policy
okay so with this sort of framework in
mind and some of the maybe drawbacks
that we've seen of policy search where
are we headed
now so what we're going to look at now
is policy gradient estimation okay so
none of these methods that we just saw
with local search that none of those use
the gradient information of our policy
okay and so we can sort of get more
information out of how to improve our
policy if we do look at the gradient of
our policy but why would we want to
estimate the gradient well the reason is
that we want to use that for
optimization okay so we have our policy
Pi of theta we we know we can estimate
the utility of that policy now we want
to look at how can we use gradient
information of this parameterized policy
to improve our
policy so when we're talking about
gradients I think the most natural place
that we would start is with looking at a
finite difference method okay and so
that's where we're going to start
with gradient estimation
here
so for finite difference what we're
going to start with is just looking at
the definition of the gradient right so
what we want to get to here is an
expression for the gradient with respect
to Theta of U of
theta okay so just from the definition
of the gradient this will be the partial
derivative of U with respect to Theta
1 and then that will be we'll just do
that n for each of our n parameters
right so then with respect to Theta
n okay so that's just definition of the
gradient that we're working with what
the finite difference method does is
basically just let's approximate this
gradient okay so what we're going to do
here is say this is approximately equal
to U of theta plus Delta times this
basis Vector we'll talk about what this
basis Vector is minus U of
theta over Delta okay so we do that for
our first parameter and remember just
from the definition of a derivative
right with a with a derivative we're
just looking at the limit of this
expression as Delta goes to zero so with
our finite difference we're just saying
okay we'll take a small enough Delta and
sort of call this Good Enough okay
that's that's our finite difference
approximation so we then repeat this for
each of our parameters so this will then
be U of theta plus Delta the N basis
Vector minus U of
theta over
Delta okay so what's what's that basis
Vector well so E1 it's very simple it's
just telling us which indic of this
Vector is not zero so E1 will just look
like this where we have one in the first
index and then Zer all the way
down okay and then similarly n the nth
base basis Vector is just Zer and then
the last component is one so that's all
the basis Vector is okay and so what
we're doing
here is we're just looking at our
Theta Vector right we have our theta1 to
Theta
n and all I'm saying in that first one
is let me add some small Delta to my
Theta my first component here only the
first component let me add some small
Delta let me evaluate the utility there
and look at the difference okay and
that's all we're doing to estimate that
that partial derivative of the first
term we then do that for each of our n
parameters okay and so for for each one
of these notice that what we have to do
to compute this right we have to do a
new set of M policy rollouts okay so
first we have to do a set of n policy
roll outs to estimate this
utility then when we change just that
Theta one we have to do a new set of M
roll outs and then for every single one
of these we have to do another new set
of M rollouts okay so again that's a lot
of of roll outs that we're having to do
so that's one of the drawbacks the other
is that sort of like local search right
we're we're only changing one of these
thetas each time we're doing this okay
so not super robust in that estimate
that we're going to be
getting so an extension of the finite
difference method is just looking at
basically same thing but how can we do
this a little bit more
smartly
so the way we're going to do that is
just with linear regression okay so this
is called the regression gradient but
what it comes down to is just doing
linear regression uh to estimate this
gradient so we're going to introduce
this Delta Theta Matrix here and what
this Delta Theta is
is basically we're just going to have
this uh Delta Theta one
here and we're going to transpose that
and we're going to break this down here
but we're going to do this Delta Theta
so this perturbation here is what you
can think about that as we're going to
do that M different times so there's a
lot of M's here so don't get confused
with the M's um so we have M different
perturbations here so looking again at
our at our Theta
vector
one of these Delta thetas so this first
Delta Theta what we do is we go and we
just randomly perturb each component of
our Theta Vector so for Theta 1 we add
some random perturbation Theta 2 add
some random perturbation we do that all
the way down to our Theta n just adding
random perturbation to each one of those
we then take that Delta Theta which is
just a random perturbation and we just
lay it flat in this Matrix here okay so
we have n components that we've just
laid laid flat we're doing that random
perturbation M different times okay so
the dimensions of this Delta Theta are M
by n okay so just random perturbation
that we've laid flat and we're doing
that random perturbation M different
times yes
question from like the last like change
value yes yes so the uh the Delta Theta
here we so we start with so the question
was is the random perturbation from the
last uh like the initial Theta that you
were starting with and yes that's
correct so we have some initial Theta we
then look at perturbing that so just
adding some random perturbation to that
and then that becomes our our Delta
Theta here okay so similarly we can
write out the Delta U Now using this
Delta
Theta and that is just very similar to
what we have with the finite
difference that's just U of theta so
whatever initial Theta we were working
with
plus Delta Theta 1 minus U of
theta and then we're going to do that
again M different times now because we
have M Delta thetas here so this will be
U of theta plus Delta Theta
M minus U of
theta okay so that becomes our Delta
U and now what you can sort of think
about like in the scalar case
right if we want to look at the SL of a
line right what we would say for the for
the scal case is well that's just Delta
uh Delta U over Delta Theta right just
sort of the rise over run relationship
okay that's not what we're doing here
because this these are vectors here so
this doesn't make any sense but just
sort of mapping that back to give you
that intuition of in the scalar case if
we wanted to approximate this slope of a
line we would just do Delta U over Delta
Theta so we're going to do a very
similar thing along that similar idea
IDE just using linear regression right
because we have our Delta U we have our
Delta Theta what we want is our gradient
with respect to U of theta okay so we're
just going to now this is just a linear
regression problem that we can set up
here so the solution to this is just
going to be the gradient with respect to
Theta well that's approximately equal
to Delta Theta the pseudo inverse of
Delta Theta so we're going to talk about
this and then times our Delta
U okay so we just want to check the
dimensions here to make sure this makes
sense right so our Delta U well that
just has M components right so this is M
by1 Delta Theta was M byn but we took
the suo inverse of it so that gives us n
by m
now so when we multiply those two
together we're left with n by one and we
know that's what our gradient should be
okay so what is this pseudo inverse of
Delta Theta well the pseudo inverse just
gives us the least squares estimate here
for our linear regression problem okay
so the pseudo inverse is just the
general form of an inverse when our
Matrix Delta Theta here might not
necessarily be invertible so if we
actually wanted to go and write out the
expression for Delta Theta pseudo
inverse that would involve taking the
singular value decomposition but in
python or Julia there's just a built-in
p inv so it's just like
this P inv function that you can call
and that will give you the pseudo
inverse so it will do that singular
value decomposition for you okay so it's
just the general form of getting this uh
least squares estimate here between our
Delta thetas and Delta
U's okay so how how does this help us
how is this better than what we saw with
the finite difference method well for
one and I'd say the main thing is that
now
you're looking at this Delta Theta so
you're looking at this perturbation
among all of your n parameters not just
one of them at a time okay and then
you're repeating that M different
times and each time you're repeating
that you're doing a new set of rollouts
here so we still have that problem where
you have to do a new set of rollouts for
each of these but this gives us a a
little smoother estimate right it's a
little more robust because we're looking
at sort of the net effect of all of
these small changes in our Theta Vector
question soric can you motivate um
taking that L again starting from the
fact that we have Delta U and how does
that like how does the L end up as the
reg estimate good question so the
question was how do we sort of get here
uh using this linear regression idea so
I think one way to think about it is
that before before getting to here right
we would have this idea of Delta U would
be equal to uh should be Delta
AA times this gradient estimate right
and maybe the best way to think about
this at least how I like to think about
it is if you think about just like
looking at the slope of a line here
right so where this would be our our U
and this would be our Theta so when
we're looking at the slope of this right
we're just
saying can everyone see this or is the
podium blocking
it everyone okay all right so when we're
looking at the slope here we can just
say well this is Delta U right this is
Delta Theta so we're looking at sort of
that and that's what I was saying before
is like Delta Delta U over Delta Theta
is what we're interested in so when we
get this here this is sort of like right
it's not at all exact because we're
working with vectors and matrices here
so this is like Delta U over Delta Theta
with this inverse not equivalent at all
but just sort of that's the that's the
idea to have in mind yes why not
Inver good question so the question was
why is Delta Theta not invertible in the
general case well for one if you have M
different from n then you could have
sort of a like what we call a short
Matrix right and so that wouldn't that
wouldn't be an invertible because it's
not Square to begin with but you could
also have issues with like the rank of
the Delta Theta Matrix since you're
doing these random perturbations it's
not necessarily guaranteed to be
invertible
yes Matrix the
number this Matrix here yeah yes so the
question was what is n what is m n here
is the number of parameters that we have
in our Theta uh Theta vector and then m
is just the number of these random
perturbations that we're doing and then
but then we also like mentioned we have
M rollouts that we're doing as well but
those are different M's so we're we're
using a lot of M's
here
yep yes and just to be clear all the
pations are just completely random for
each of those like M rows yep yeah so
the the question was are all of these
perturbations just random yeah so you
could use like some how you like what
type of random noise you use that's sort
of up to you but yeah it's just if we
use like a just some gaussian noise we
could just add that gaussian noise to
each uh
component okay so that's the regression
gradient now with that we still have the
issue that we have to do this new set of
roll outs for each of these right and I
think you asked about that earlier like
isn't this still a lot of of new roll
outs to compute and the answer is yes
that that is still an issue so where
we're sort of going now is we want to
look at just an analytical expression
for this
gradient so if
you recall from before we had this
expression for U of
theta where we had it as the this
expectation which we could write as the
probability of that trory occurring
times the reward we receive along that
trajectory okay so that's sort of where
we're going to start from right this is
just what we saw before with this
expectation over
trajectories so we're going to start
from here and our goal is to get some
analytical expression of this gradient
okay so no more finite difference
approximation here we want to work this
out so we're just going to take the
gradient now we're going to say gradient
with respect to U of
theta
and so we can just look at this integral
now our integral is with respect to tal
so we can bring this uh gradient with
respect to Theta inside the integral and
we just get this
expression okay so nothing too crazy yet
right and now what we're going to do is
just multiply by one okay we're just
going to Simply multiply by one so we
have this P Pi of to over P Pi of to
and then we still have this expression
here so still gradient with respect to
Theta P Pi of
t r of
T so you might be saying why would we do
that why did we just multiply by one
right that doesn't that doesn't look too
nice of an expression to work with but
what we can notice is that we this
allows us to sort of rewrite some things
in terms of log
probabilities so the fact that we can
sort of notice is if we look at the
gradient with respect to
Theta of log P Pi of
C right if we take the gradient of log
of theta right that would give us one
over Theta right so just the derivative
of log of x is 1 /x so if we take the
gradient with respect to this and we use
the chain rule this would give us 1 P Pi
of to and then chain rule says take the
gradient of the outside term time
gradient of the inside term right so the
gradient of the inside term is just
gradient with respect TOA P Pi of t Okay
so this was just the chain rule to get
this simplification here okay all we did
was take the chain rule of This this
term here but now notice this gradient
with respect to Theta P Pi of to shows
up in this expression that's why we
multiplied by one so now we can
substitute this back in okay we can
substitute this expression in here and
we'll have the loog we'll bring the log
inside okay so this expression up here
becomes P Pi of
to gradient with respect to Theta log P
Pi of
to R of to D
to now you might be saying well this
doesn't look a whole lot better than
what we started with in fact this this
kind of looks worse right but um I
assure you we are we are getting
somewhere here okay so what we can
notice here is that this is just an
expectation now we've just sort of
Rewritten the expectation that we
started with in a different form Now
using the log probability okay so it'll
come together I promise you so we can
rewrite this now as the expectation over
trajectories of the gradient with
respect to Theta log P Pi of to
R of
to
okay so that's where we're at now we're
getting somewhere but now we're sort of
focused on this term right we want to
simplify this a little bit because we
need to know right what is this P Pi of
to what's the probability of a
trajectory occurring when following
policy Pi okay so that's what that's
what we're going to talk about now is
how do we how do we get that
probability
so I might I'm going to come over here
just so you can finish writing that down
if you are so probability of a
trajectory right remember that a
trajectory is just a sequence of states
and actions so we have state one we took
action A1 and then we can just continue
this out right all the way up to the
depth so State D action
D okay so that's just trajectory
sequence of states and actions what
we're asking now is what is the
probability of this trajectory occurring
okay and I think a good way to think
about that is back to sort of the the
picture we had with the marov decision
process right where we had some
state from that state we took some
action that action gave us some reward
here and then we transitioned to a new
state
so when we're talking about the
probability of this trajectory
occurring what does that look like well
we have to start somewhere right what's
the probability that we start in that
initial State okay and that's back to
the B of s term where like what that's
saying what's this probability of this
state occurring okay what's the
probability that we are starting in this
state so that's where that's our sort of
starting point for this probability
expression right just what's the
probability that we start in that state
now that we're in state one so we're in
state one we take action A1 what's the
probability that we transition to state
two okay so that's just our transition
probability right probability that we
transition to state two given we were in
state one and took action
A1 but we're not done there there's one
more term and this specific term is when
we're working with stochastic policies
Okay so a stochastic policy is different
from a deterministic policy okay so we
write our stochastic policy like
this so that's our stochastic policy
where this is a distribution over
actions given our current state that's
different from a deterministic policy
which we would write just like
this okay that would just tell us we're
in some State we're going to take an
action our stochastic policy is a
distribution now we're in some State I
now have a distribution of actions that
I could take so I'm not always going to
take the same action in the same state
okay so that's that's what we're we're
saying when we're talking about
stochastic policies the reason we're
working with stochastic policies in this
likelihood ratio policy gradient method
will become
clearer but for now just just focus on
the fact this is a distribution over
actions okay which means that we're not
just done with this transition term
because we also have the prob that we
took that
action so the probability we took action
A1 in state
one
okay so we can continue this out now all
the way for our entire trajectory but we
can just write it a little simpler with
some product notation here where we have
P of
S1 then this becomes a product now we'll
say from k equal 1 to
D of the probability that we
transitioned to State k + 1 given we
were in state K and took action a
k then times the probability that we
took action K in state
SK okay so that's the expression for
this probability term that we had over
here any questions on how we got that
probability or or why we're doing
this yes so
what's the letter on top of the product
ah yes the question was what's this
letter that is D so that's the depth of
our
trajectory
yep okay so from here it's it's all
downhill from here all right we're just
now we just we have this expression we
just need to take the log of it and then
take the gradient okay so those are the
next two steps we're going to do so
there's a light at the end of the tunnel
here so first we're just going to take
the log of this we know the nice part
about logs is this is just one giant
product here so when we take the log of
a product it just becomes the sum of
logs right so that's all we're going to
do we're going to take the log of this
and when we take the log of this it
becomes log P of
S1 this product here becomes a sum so we
get the sum from K = 1 to
D of log of this term so log
PK + 1
given we were in SK took action
AK and then the last term here is this
Pi Theta so then plus
log Pi
Theta a k given
SK okay so one out of two steps done now
the last thing we have to do is just
take the gradient of that
expression so you might be like oh no we
have to take the gradient now but it's
very nice here in this case because what
happens when we take the gradient with
respect TOA of this term it just drops
out right it doesn't depend Ona so that
goes
away does this term depend on Theta no
so we can also just get rid of that term
and that's a huge result when working
with stochastic policies okay that's why
I made this differentiation here about
we're working with stochastic policies
because when we're looking at this
likelihood ratio policy gradient it does
not depend on the transition model when
we take the gradient of the log
probability this transition model drops
out and that's a huge result which we'll
see sort of a real world example of that
in a second but that's something you
want to keep in mind is when I look at
the gradient of this log probability
this transition model does not show up
okay and that's that's a really nice
result for us so all we're left now is
the gradient with respect to Theta of
this term okay so we'll rewrite this
over
here
okay so the expression that we come to
at the end is going to be this
expectation over trajectories the sum
from k equal 1 to our depth times the
gradient with respect to Theta log Pi
Theta
AK given
SK times the reward along the
trajectory okay so that's that's the
sort of end result of the likelihood
ratio policy gradient now you might be
saying well but we didn't take the
gradient of this yet like what is what
is this here well remember for our
particular policy that we've
parameterized right we can typically
take the gradient with respect to that
so if if Pi Theta is a neural network
right we can evaluate the gradient of
that neural network through back
propagation if Pi Theta is some other
function that we've set up we typically
can we know the gradient of that
function with respect to our parameters
so this is good news for us that this is
the only term that's showing up in this
gradient because very often in practice
when we've set up our own parameterized
policy we can take the gradient of that
policy okay so this is a a nice spot to
be in for
us any questions on how we how we got to
here this point yes sorry backing a
little bit you had the previous
expression i w we substit in the log of
like the gradient of the log how did you
end up with that expression so not that
one even before below
that one on the very top of this board
this how' you end up with that
expression ah yes okay so the question
is how did we get this expression so
this expression typically called like
the log derivative trick I don't really
like that name because it's just it's
just the chain rule you're just taking
the gradient of the log probability so
you can think about if I had if like
instead of thinking about this if I just
had log of x
right the derivative of log of x is just
1 /x right so when I'm taking the
gradient with respect to Theta of this
term I'm just taking the gradient of the
outside which is one over P of to and
then times the gradient of the inside
yeah so just chain rule there and they
call it the log derivative trick but I
don't know it's not a trick to me it's
just you're taking the gradients
right okay
so I mentioned
that it's a nice sort of result that we
don't have the transition model here
that the transition model doesn't show
up and so this is just sort of an
example to get you thinking about if I
wanted to if I had this robotic arm and
I wanted to use either the likelihood
ratio policy gradient or one of the
extensions that we'll talk about to
train a policy to sort of manipulate and
pick up all of these this diverse set of
objects if I had to do that and I needed
to know the transition model right
that's going to be pretty tedious
because I have to think about okay if
I'm picking up a lemon and I move my
manipulator in this direction what's
that going to do to the lemon now if I
came from the other direction instead
how's that going to change the lemon
right so I have to think about all of
these different cases and then I also
have to do that well what if I'm picking
up an apple instead right so knowing
that transition probability can be
pretty tedious not impossible right
there's simulators out there that do
this and that's available but it just
sort of makes our lives easier right if
we don't have to think about what is
this transition probability because it
just dropped out of our gradient
expression okay so that's just one of
the reasons that that's such a nice
result and that that example on the
right actually from open AI was trained
using proximal policy optimization so
time permitting we'll hopefully get to
that by the end of the lecture just to
sort of give you a sense of of where
we're
going
okay so now sort of where we're at here
with the likelihood ratio policy
gradient we we have this estimate and
it's an unbiased estimate but it has
pretty high variance okay so what do we
mean when we're talking about bias and
variance here so this this image that we
have is
showing here for the high bias case Okay
so the red is the true value the black
is the our mean estimate okay so when we
have high bias our mean is deviating
from the True Value when we have high
variance you can see that there's this
large spread in the possible values uh
that we could have okay so what where we
sort of want to be is over over here
where we have low bias and low variance
where we're sitting at right now with
our likelihood ratio policy gradient is
here we have low bias but we have high
variance so now what we're going to
focus on is how can we reduce the
variance of this estimate and I think
that goes back to your question earlier
about don't these rollout methods give
us very high variance and the answer is
yes especially for when we're working
with the likelihood ratio policy
gradient so how can we now reduce that
variance that's what we're going to talk
about now
and one other thing just to keep in mind
is that the variance of this estimate
generally increases with rollout depth
okay so looking at this trajectory here
as our depth gets further and further
into the future the variance of our
estimate increases so why might that be
the case well you can think about right
as as you go further into the future it
gets harder and harder to attribute this
reward that I received like somewhere in
the middle was that because one of the
early actions I took or was it from
something I did you know in the middle
which which action attributed to that
right so like a similar example if you
get a promotion right what specific
action led to that promotion occurring
was it what you ate for breakfast that
morning or was it you know 20 years
before when you went to some event at
your college and you met somebody who
then ended up working at that company
that then got you a job there right
which which specific action was it that
led to that promotion okay so that's
sort of what we're talking about here is
it it gets harder to sort of map that
causality in these actions as our
trajectory depth gets
longer and so that's what we're looking
at sort of reducing now and the reward
to go is one way that we can go about
doing
this okay so reward to go we're going to
start from from this expression that we
have so we're starting from the result
of the likelihood ratio policy gradient
and I think the best way to sort of
think about what what the reward to go
is trying to do is by looking at a
timeline here
so we have at the start right we take
some action our first action we get some
reward here we then take a new action we
get some new
reward we repeat this right so now we're
at action K we get some reward K and
then after that we get we take action k+
one we get reward K plus
one but what you might see here is when
we're looking at this sum over our
trajectory and looking at action K
specifically that action has no
influence over the rewards that occurred
in the past right that we we cannot this
action here cannot change any of those
rewards we got in the past it can only
change what we do now or in the future
so if we have an agent here that agent
when it's looking at what action to take
it should not care about any good things
it did in the past any mistakes that it
made right it should forget about that
and only focus on the future okay I
didn't intend to get so deep there but
there's some there's some philosophy
here in this reward to go so okay so if
we have action AK we're basically saying
we don't want or we have no influence
over what any of these rewards are right
we can't we can't change what those
rewards are only now or in the future
okay okay and so that's what the reward
to go is trying to correct for is this
causality of actions and
rewards so how we're going to go about
this is we just look at this R of to
right is just the discounted reward that
we receive along that
trajectory so R of to is just the sum
from K = 1 to D of R of K gamma to the K
minus
one okay so it's just the discounted
reward that we're getting along these
trajectories what we're doing with the
reward to go approach is we're just
going to split up this sum okay we're
just going to split up the sum and then
we're going to simplify it a little
bit okay so just writing out the same
expression that we have but then we're
going to substitute in the sum so this
is just the expectation sum K = 1 to
D gradient with respect to Theta this is
the log
here okay so now instead of R of toar
we're just going to bring that sum in
but instead of just writing it how we've
written it up there we're going to split
it up into two separate sums
yes when you say RFK over there that is
distinct from gamma of Kus one it says
that R of K is R function of K like r at
time K yes yes good point so the
question was when we write R of K with
these parentheses that's not an exponent
that's like sort of the index to our R
of K whereas gamma to the K minus one is
a is a
exponent good
question okay so we're just going to
split up that sum here so how we're
going to split it up is just by
introducing this new index that we're
going to call L so we're just going to
go from L this L is different from our K
index here okay so we're going from l =
1 to K
minus1 and that's going to be R of L
gamma to the L minus
one so we've done that and then we're
just we're just splitting up that sum
here so now we're going to have
plus Lal
K
to to D here okay and that's going to be
R of L gamma to the L minus1
one okay so all we've done we just took
R of to we wrote out the expression for
R of to is that summation and then we
just split up that summation from k
equal 1 to D now we're just going Lal 1
to K minus one and lals K to D okay
that's all we've done why would we do
this well remember our timeline of
events here at action K we're saying we
want our agent to forget about the past
right don't worry about what happened in
the past only focus on the future so if
we want our agent to move on and forget
about the past we're just going to drop
the past and focus on the future okay so
all of those terms there are terms
reward terms that occurred in the past
we're now only focused on the reward
terms that occur now or in the future
okay and so we can just rewrite this
slightly as if we factor out a gamma to
the K minus one this is just sort of
Convention of How It's typically written
this becomes still lals K to D
R of L now it's just gamma to the lus
K and what this term here is called is
the reward to go so we call this the
reward to go all it is is just sort of
correcting for that reward action
causality okay so now if we rewrite this
whole
expression using this reward to go what
we're left with is just this so we still
have this sum on the
outside
and now it's just gamma to the K minus1
time R of K to
go okay so all we did here was sort of
just remove those terms that occurred in
the past so that when we're looking at
action K that's only being sort of
weighted here in this uh expectation
it's only being weighted by the rewards
that occur now or in the future okay
that's the reward too approach and the
nice part about this is that it leads to
a decrease in variance okay why does it
lead to a decrease in variance well
we've sort of made the signal a little
bit clearer now we've made that
causality a little bit clearer instead
of just having this large reward term
that's multiplying every single action
that we're looking at we're only waiting
it now by the rewards that that action
can influence okay okay any questions on
reward to
go yes clarification again
um uh what the notation switch was like
there to the L yes okay so that the
question was what's the notation switch
we did from here to here so at this step
we just split up the the sum up there so
we just went from L equals one to K
minus one and then K to D so just going
it's the same thing from 1 to D but we
just split it up then going here
so let me draw this sort of to
distinguish them uh all we did here was
we just factored out a gamma to the K
minus one from this term okay so we just
brought gamma to the K minus one out in
front and what that left us with was
just gamma to the L minus K instead of L
minus one so if you just multiply gamma
to the K minus one back inside it'll
bring us back to here and the reason we
did that is just sort of for convention
the reward to go is written typically
like this
yes why are both gamma what raised to L
minus one why are both gamas raised to L
minus one okay so yeah that's a good
question so why are the gamma here
raised to L minus one well it comes back
from this expression right which is just
the discounted reward into the future so
you can think about when along this
timeline right at time step one we get
the immediate reward but then at time
step two we have a discount so we
multiply that by gamma because we're
discounting the future rewards so then
gamma K will then have a factor gamma K
minus one and we'll just continue that
out yes we apply the reward to does the
reward term go inside the
cation does the reward oh this term here
yes yeah well so it's it's waiting each
of those actions in the sum there so
each of those actions we're multiplying
by the like when we're doing the sum k
equals 1 to
D is that does that answer your
question yeah okay did you also I
think oh yes yes between between this
one yeah just those two here right yeah
so the the L's here are different from
uh different from each other yeah from
each other yeah this L is only for this
sum this L is only for
this thanks
yeah okay
so one other thing we can do now to
decrease this variance is what's called
Baseline subtraction and Baseline
subtraction we're just starting from the
reward to go expression and now we're
just subtracting some baseline off of
that okay
so uh sort of the the reason why we're
doing this is if you think about like
this example where you're in some
State and you have three possible
actions available to you and each of
those actions give you plus a thousand
reward when you first see this you might
be like awesome this is a great state to
be in right like no matter what I do I'm
getting plus a th000 reward that's
that's
great but when we're talking about
estimating the gradient and using that
gradient information to sort of change
our policy parameters this plus a th in
each of these different actions is not
really giving us a whole lot of
information to work with on how we
should change our policy right maybe
maybe like in a in a global sense right
it would give us some way to say well we
want to get to this state but just
looking at this state in specifically
right the plus a th for each action
every in that state is the same to us so
what the reward to go what the what the
Baseline subtraction method is saying is
instead of looking at the net reward
that you receive let's look at the
reward relative to some baseline okay so
in this case we could choose the
Baseline that we want to use as the
average reward from the actions that we
get okay so in that
case when we look at the the Baseline
reward that would be a thousand right
because each action is giving us a
thousand so now when we look at this
reward from this action relative to that
Baseline it'll be zero right because
it's just average it's just an average
action similar for this one and this one
now if instead we had like plus a
million
here then when looking at this reward
relative to the average so relative to
our Baseline that's going to say well
hey this is a pretty good action right
it's way better than the average action
that we had so let's sort of shift our
policy parameter to get us to take that
action okay so that's the whole idea of
Baseline subtraction don't look at just
the net reward look at the reward
relative to some baseline okay what
Baseline you choose that's up to you
there's many different baselines out
there so you could use average reward
there's a proof that you can get sort of
the minimum variance Baseline um but
really the the main idea is just using a
baseline sort of also helps you to bring
out the signal bring out the signal in
that policy rollout of what what actions
are actually more beneficial relative to
some baseline okay so that's that's
Baseline subtraction just another method
that we can use to decrease the variance
of that
estimate
yes for every or
you you uh so the question was is your
Baseline different for every uh specific
action you're looking at or do you set
it globally and the answer would be it
depends so you could have a baseline
that depends that is action dependent
right that gets a little complicated so
in the general case you can just set a
global Baseline right you could just set
the Baseline to be the mean reward you
received across all actions so that's
one option but it's sort of up to you in
how you set that
Baseline okay so just to sort of recap
what we've seen we started with finite
difference and saw that we can estimate
the gradient using that finite
difference we then saw we could get a
little more robust estimate using linear
regression and then we looked at the
likelihood ratio which gave us basically
an analytical expression for doing this
uh but it was a pretty high variance
estimate so then we were looking at how
can we reduce the variance of that
estimate okay so that's that is our
policy gradient estimation okay so now
we have some estimate of the policy
gradient and you might be thinking like
okay wow that felt like a lot of math
like that likelihood ratio derivation
was kind of along like why why did we do
all of this work what was it for um and
so now we're going to put our work to
use for us with policy gradient
optimization okay so the whole reason we
were looking at those gradient estimates
were so that we could optimize our
policy okay we wanted to use the
gradient information to sort of guide
our our policy
Improvement so that's what we're going
to be talking about
now so what we're going to start with is
just basic gradient ascent okay so when
we're doing gradient Ascent we're trying
to sort of maximize the utility okay and
and how we're going to do that is just
by taking these sort of iterative steps
so what we're showing on the left here
is the true function that we're working
with on the right is sort of the uh the
the Contour plot of that function okay
so the initial point that we're starting
at is this white Point here so that's
our initial parameters and then we're
just going to look at what's what's the
direction of the gradient there and then
we're going to step in that direction
okay so all we're doing is we're
updating our parameters Theta by some
fixed step size Alpha so Alpha is our
step size in this case times the
gradient of our function okay and so we
can just do this over and over and over
and based on that fixed step size that
we've set hopefully eventually we'll
converge to the
maximum step Factor step Factor yes
thank you Alpha the step
Factor so so this is a relatively nice
function right it's very smooth pretty
easy to work with and follow the
gradient to the maximum a lot of the
time the functions that we're working
with are not that nice okay so we can't
sort of just close the book right now
and say awesome let's just use gradient
Ascent let's fix our Alpha as some some
constant and go from there because the
devil is really in the details of how we
choose that Alpha
okay so so to see an example of this
right if we set Alpha to be too large
what's going to happen so if we have
just some large constant Alpha we're
going to start at this initial Theta
we're going to look at the gradient and
then we're going to step in the
direction of the gradient based on our
large Alpha and that will send us way
over to the left side here okay and now
for this visual example like all of the
gradient that's that I've drawn are not
like actually correct so don't be like
wait with an alpha there it wouldn't
actually go that way that far okay just
for visualization here um so then we'd
repeat this process now we'd look at the
gradient at this point and that would
send us shooting way over here so now
we're over here and we're going to
repeat and now we've jumped way over
there so you can see when we have too
large of an alpha we don't really
converge we're just sort of bouncing
around right and on the other side when
our Alpha is too small what would happen
Well we'd look at our gradient we'd step
and then it would just not really move
move right and we do it again and again
and we're just going to very slowly
converge okay so we're going to waste a
lot of computation there so our goal
here is that we want to be able to
optimize some approximation of this U of
theta
objective with these constraints that
our new thetas our Theta primes are not
too far from our initial starting Theta
okay that's our that's our overall goal
here so how we do that is we introduce
this constraint function and we're going
to call this constraint function G so G
is sort of like a similarity measure or
distance measure not exactly right but
it's just some way that we sort of are
measuring the distance here between our
new Theta primes against our old thetas
and we want that to be less than or
equal to some Epsilon that we're setting
as this free
parameter so the methods that we're
going to talk about in the next three
minutes um are are these four methods
that we're not going to be able to get
to all of them but we're going to start
with restricted gradient here and so the
methods the main idea that I want you to
keep in mind as we go through this is
the main two ways that these approaches
differ are one how they're forming the
objective that we're trying to optimize
and two how they're structuring that
constraint okay other than that they're
pretty much the same but they're just
taking different flavors on how we set
the objective how we set the
constraints so starting with restricted
gradient which I'd say is sort of the
simplest of these approaches we're
starting with remember we have those two
knobs objective and constraint so we're
looking at now restricted gradient how
it sets this
objective the restricted gradient method
just does a very simple first order
approximation so we're just saying okay
our true function looks like that our
current Theta is here let's look at the
gradient and that blue line becomes our
approximation of the function that we're
trying to optimize okay so we don't
actually know the true U of theta right
but we're just saying this is a pretty
pretty good estimate for us as long as
we stay close to that initial Theta
point the first order approximation
hopefully is okay so when we move to
Theta Prime now and we evaluate a new
Point what this surrogate objective is
telling us is that our new U of theta
Prime will be approximately equal to
just this first order tailor expansion
that we've done okay so this is just the
first order approximation of the true U
of theta that we're looking at at and
that's how the restricted gradient
method goes about
that so using this first order
approximation now what our optimization
problem looks like we now we we have
this U Theta Prime and our constraint
function remember that's our other knob
that we're introducing here is just this
expression here so all we're doing is
we're looking at Theta Prime minus Theta
the transpose of that this is the
identity Matrix here and then Theta
Prime minus Theta okay so that's just
the two Norm right so if we're working
in like a two-dimensional space right
that's just like the ukian distance
between our Theta and our Theta Prime so
we're just saying keep that distance
less than or equal to some Epsilon so
don't move Theta too far that's all
we're saying here that's what that
expression written out is
saying so very quickly wrapping this up
uh we can basically so so we can make
some simplifications here but
essentially what we're left with is that
restricted gradient is trying to
maximize this expression subject to
keeping our uh constraints our Theta
Prime in our Theta within some Epsilon
distance okay all of the other methods
that we didn't get to they're basically
just different variations of this where
they're changing the objective or
changing the constraint function okay so
zooming back out again now to the big
picture to wrap up all all we've done
today is we we've looked at policy
optimization right so we started with
policy search where we had some
parameterized policy and we made these
local changes to it without looking at
any gradient information then we
switched and we started looking at okay
how can I estimate the gradient of this
policy and then we sort of concluded
with looking at how can I then use that
gradient estimate to optimize my policy
subject to these constraints that I
don't move too far okay so that is
policy optimization in a nutshell I hope
that was helpful to you I hope you got
something out of it uh and we'll wrap up
here thank you all for listening and I'm
happy to take any
questions